would be put in his room while she was
sacrificing chickens
and casting spells and is that even
legal
no
so you've made a pact with the devil can
it be broken find out on this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live it's a show where we
use the light of christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today we have tammy with us welcome
welcome thank you and um and you have
such an amazing testimony and i'm
grateful for your willingness to be here
and share it with us you know this
question of
making pacts with the devil yes we might
make one curious as to your background
your upbringing
any type of involvement in that so how
about we start there where are you from
so i'm from bridgeport connecticut
born and raised
i lived there most of my life
and there i had my experiences
growing up in a lifestyle
that was oddly enough a mixture of
christianity
and also
um
a form of voodoo called santeria
wow christian voodoo
yeah
yeah it was kind of like christian yoga
we did a show
yeah it's really it's really odd how
they merge together
specifically catholicism
is really what it merges with um
and uh yeah so it actually goes together
there's some harmony there oh there's a
lot of harmony
there's a lot of harmony with
catholicism and
so what does that look like paint a
picture as someone who's
catholic as well as involved in
centuries you guys go to mass or like
well do stuff at home
yeah so my grandmother was the one who
was
involved in the santeria she was a
santera
what's that and so they're like the
she's the witch so she cast spells and
she was uh
um do they use that terminology
i'm a witch that cast spells no
i mean well in spanish they do bruja
really yeah it reminds me of you made a
video about christian witches
well i mean
so there's like the white magic and then
there's the black magic and so there's
the bruja and then there's the santera
and so the santera has like
incorporates more of the saints and
their thought to cast spells that do
more good and bring blessings rather
than
harm although they do do things to
cause harm sometimes so as a
christian you would
not you but somebody who's in this would
say i practice black magic as a
christian
why would any christian do something
that's dark or evil like that maybe they
don't know that's dark well no she's
saying that there's two different kind
there's white magic black magic so you
could be a
white witch christian or a black witch
christian well no not so much a black
witch christian if you if you're in the
into if you're a ruja then you're going
to be doing more of the evil stuff evil
stuff but i thought it was like under
this guise of santeria which is
christian voodoo yeah so santeria has
like the christian voodoo and then
there's brugeria okay yeah okay so
there's like a little divide in it and
so yeah so my family was into santeria
well with all that being said are the
techniques is that should i even call it
techniques are like
spells casting the same oh
yeah i mean you're still making doing
sacrifices animal sacrifices um
they involve a lot of they're into like
natural herbs natural um
uh with plants and so on and so forth um
they have beads baptism i was actually
baptized
sprinkle or fully immersion full
immersion in a river wow yeah full of
immersion interesting
so yeah so how it all happened was so my
my grandmother was a child of 14 right
and she grew up in puerto rico and as
she was in puerto rico she was her
parents passed away and so
she was the youngest out of the 14.
and
i don't know how she got involved in it
she ended up getting married coming to
the united states
and she got heavy into it uh where she
started to practice and do all the
rituals and so on and so i knew her but
she died when i was four
she died when i was four so i didn't get
to see all the things so a lot of the
stuff that i know about her are stories
from my mom
that she told me so my mom kind of like
picked up
a lot of what my grandmother did not in
his totality
my mom wasn't consistent enough with it
thank god
um but she was consistent enough that
there was
a demonic presence
in the house and the family and we did a
lot of the rituals on a regular basis so
where is the christianity in that oh so
um okay
so since my mother my grandmother was a
santera we had uh we lived in a really
big house and on the third floor in the
top corner room we we called it the
altar room and in this altar room it's a
polytheistic religion
and so we explain that just for people
who don't know uh polytheism so you
believe in all the gods
like every god no matter what country no
matter what origin you believe in it
which is very contradictory to the bible
in itself right and being one god
absolutely absolutely there's multiple
gods and um
they believe that you don't have a
direct connection with god you have to
use these other gods in order to connect
to god
and in order to do that you have to
appease the other gods
and so um
in this
so we had this altar room and we had
gods from like india we had native
american gods we had
um there was like
different um
from haiti from africa from and catholic
i remember we had a big bible it was
like it was huge and a rosary with beads
like that big
that sat on the main area of the altar
and then there was like all various
different statues for different things
and were there different religious books
as well or just the bible and then
statues i can't remember okay like it
seems like a lot to keep up with yeah it
was it was a room filled with a whole
bunch of stuff okay so it was it was a
lot of things and also spells there's a
lot of spells in there
was there was this like a secret thing
is that why it was upstairs and not in
the living room or
is there a secret aspect to this
religion yes so you're not you're you
can't really uh expose too much of what
you're doing
i mean people know that you're doing it
but if you expose too much
then you know things can happen for
example um it was said
that
it was said that we we all have a
guardian that we're born with
right and these guardians
and i i fully believe now that they're
demonic spirits
um
they're there to protect you they're
your guide and they're your guardian and
they're the ones that you pray to in
order to get what it is that you need or
you know whatever it is that you need
and so um
when you
my mother started to go to
essentia after my my grandmother had
passed away when i was four
she started going to a santera and the
reason why she went to the santera was
because my father
had left
and
she wanted him back
and also there was like financial issues
and so forth so she would go ahead and
go to this house
la casa and
and she would do these rituals
over there and i have so many i mean i
was actually writing down like all the
things that's happened
um and
the flashbacks are just i right now just
talking about it i could really go back
into into seeing all the things that i
saw and it was really scary
i remember feeling that that that that
that
demonic
that presence that fear and even to this
day
i know this is going to sound very weird
even to this day if i meet a person
who
is involved in like demonic things
i could feel
it
i could feel it and i
can't stand next to them yeah to me
that's not that doesn't sound weird it
sounds like you have a familiarity with
that and you have a sensitivity to that
where some of us it's so
foreign that we don't pick up on it yeah
i was gonna say you were a child being
raised up around this yeah you'd think
it would be almost normal but you said
you felt a demonic something dark about
it so even as a kid
being raised around it you could tell
there's something dark about it well
here's the here's the thing there was
because i went to catholic school on top
of it you know because you know it's
heavily involved in catholicism and so i
went to catholic school and as i was
going to catholic school you know they
they
use a different bible and they also
speak more about mary and the saints and
all those other stuff
and they don't really speak about jesus
but i remember they spoke
one time about jesus and i fell in love
with him
i fell in love with him and i knew that
he was very different than all of them
and all of this stuff
i mean like elementary school yes yes
and so that actually played a big role
as to how i got out
you know um
so
you have these spirits and
going back to the to the story so it was
said by my mom that
when she was going to this santera
that uh she actually stole
our guardian
she stole our guardian
and
um that's why we had
these calamities now when i talk about
calamities like we had
this intense demonic presence over us
and it was said that it was because our
guardian was gone and so all these bad
things kept happening and i mean
it was so unreal like bad thing after
bad thing after bad thing after bad
thing that it was it was like a bad
movie like our lives were a bad movie
and we couldn't break from that that
cycle and even now to this day
um my family still can't really break
back from the cycle and it's still
hovering over over them they're still
chris i mean they're christian and
they're still practicing they're not
christian
they kind of sort of practice it like my
siblings don't
my mom still has some statues um
incidentally when we had moved from our
original house that house that had the
altar
um
i took the moving truck and i went to
the dump and i took all the boxes with
all of those relics and i threw them in
the tub
i was gonna mention that because you
said something about these uh
i don't know what you call them
paraphernalia or whatever but like when
i was
not a believer i still had an attraction
to religious art i just liked it in
general so i had collected buddha
statues and all these things yeah and
then when i came to be a christian i
still had those things like openly
displayed because i just thought it was
cool art like yeah
and then i started studying with this
guy and he was like
i don't know if you should have those
and i was like i mean it's just art to
me it's not like i worship them or
anything they're just there and he goes
yeah but you know there might be some
kind of spiritual attachment or
something and it convicted me and i
threw him in the trash and um i wondered
if you had any kind of
insight on that like can
demonic forces attach themselves to like
idols and things that people might just
consider pieces of art in their home
i believe so yeah i believe so because
my mom has it in her house and when i go
over her house you know i have to i have
to stay prayed up because um when i go
over there it really is hard and then
afterwards i have like a lot of
nightmares
afterwards um and uh the spirit that's
just there that that is with them or
with her is really
um
aggressive and angry and
demonic in many ways i believe it's an
invitation i don't think there's like a
spirit that's like possessing the little
statue itself or whatever but i think
you're telling the spirit world you're
welcoming it yeah it's an open door and
i think there's more of that stuff than
we're aware of yeah you know i think
that's why people have so many
struggles in their life they don't know
what things are in their home that yes
you know i don't even know probably
go ahead that's why it's one of the ten
commandments yeah
i have any other gods or idols yeah no
any graven images or anything like that
you know on the one hand you could think
well god is very possessive like he
wants us for his own but he's probably
also protecting us from
the devil having access to us yeah right
i think that there's there's a there's a
god winks at our ignorance yeah so i
don't think that if it's not an idol to
us
you know and and you're ignorantly
partaking in in something
you know like that that is dedicated to
i don't think god is going to say oh
right but to bounce off of that
when that friend of mine brought it to
my attention you should get rid of those
because they're pagan gods then it was
then that knowledge was brought to my
attention
exactly yeah i wanted to make sure that
we
convey that that
you can't just willfully live in
ignorance so that you don't have to do
anything
no don't tell me because i just want to
live right
absolutely yeah it reminds me of um
i was just to say we do have a
responsibility to seek truth yes
right yeah it reminds me of one time um
like i think it was almost about a year
and a half ago i went to india and like
i used to kind of be a new age so i
really liked all like the boho colorful
elephants things like that yeah and i
remember i brought back some relics so
it was like those long um
those beaded strings that have like the
elephants on them the painted ones
and i just remember i brought it hung
them up in my room when i got back to
hong kong and i was like i was like man
these are so pretty like something about
going to india felt so familiar and then
i remember one of my co-workers said to
me he said well you know it's like the
the um home of new age when he said that
i was like wow i started to think about
that
and so um i remember just looking at
them and thinking like
what do these really mean because in
asia it's very hard to buy something
without a spiritual meaning to it like
anywhere you go it's like oh this will
bring protect protection this will bring
riches yeah and so i remember just
looking up what it meant and those are
actually um they protect evil spirit i
mean they protect you from evil spirits
but it's like god can protect us from
that jesus trying to protect us from
that so it's like it's really these
spirits are on the same side they give
you this illusion of good and bad yes
yeah i used to wear a pentagram and the
meaning of it is protection from evil so
you'd think oh as a christian i could
wear this but
you don't need protection from evil
unless you're inviting evil in so it's
kind of like you know they would
you would put a pentagram on the floor
and then you'd start doing these rituals
because you're playing around with
demonic spirits yeah it's also kind of
backwards thinking because you're going
to the enemy to act protection from the
enemy right
it's true and you know he plays you like
that like he plays the game just like
that that you are in in this evil and so
he can control
you know
he could back off from those things and
if you ask him to just so that you can
be more
grounded in what he wants you to be
grounded in
yeah so walk us through what was your
involvement as a child as a teenager
even maybe as an adult in santoria yeah
so
i had a very uh troubled childhood you
know my father left you know my mom was
you know left to take care of the four
of us plus we had a mentally disabled uh
relative who lived with us on top of it
so five of us plus herself in this big
house and so she was always working and
so she would lean on on heavily on those
things my dad left
and when he left you know she really
couldn't do it alone she really couldn't
do it at all she needed help
and um she turned to what she knew
and that was this this thing and so when
she was going to the santera and trying
to get help and trying to get the money
things and
you know we did the ritual where we were
baptized in the river we had to wear the
beads
we
would have to get bathed in this
mixture there's a plant i can't remember
it but when i smell it i hate it it
drives me nuts or something no it's not
sage
it's it's a bush that's like a natural
mosquito repellent and it has a very
strong odor very pretty citronella
not citronella it has it doesn't have a
citrusy smell
and it has like these little pods that
split into four
i can't even i couldn't even begin to
find it on google but
anyhow
she would bathe us regularly in that
thing and then she would do the rituals
where she would burn an incense and put
it in each room and say this little
chant and you know have the candles and
then she would do the offerings for the
for the saints um particularly
i i guess our guardian liked red red
delicious apples and rum
and so she would always put a glass you
know a glass of rum and a red delicious
apple towards them and
so
growing up doing that
and then also having the presence every
time i went to sleep
at the end of my bed there was always a
man who stood at the corner a shadow
every night
and so i would sleep with my covers over
my head because i knew he was there he
was always there i'm afraid of this man
i was afraid of this man but my mom told
me that i did not need to be afraid of
him because he was my guardian wow
and so every night every night did he
ever do anything like
um
a couple of times he
i man this is so weird talking about
this oh please be open about it yes
there's a lot of people that are dealing
with similar situations there are times
where we were um very sickly kids
and there were times where i would i
hated getting sick because every time i
got sick it was the time when he would
try to kill me
so he would try to suffocate me
i would have these
really intense hallucinations um death
was always a big thing in my life by the
by the age of eight i had already
planned how i was gonna kill myself
you know so it was it was really
you know intense and demonic and dark
and you know i would see spirits walking
all the time
after i got baptized i was actually
given the gift of dreams and so they
talk to you
in your dreams through your dreams
they'll give you either dreams or
premonitions or
intuition is the things that they lean
on would you share those terrifying
experiences with your mom and she's
still telling you that there he's a good
guardian angel or whatever
i never was able to relate it to him now
like looking back now i know it was him
when i would tell her about my bad
dreams she would always say that if
something was happening to call on her
name
to call on her name because they are
scared of the presence of your parents
or your mother or something like that
and that's not a red flag but okay yeah
yeah it never worked by the way
you know within this religion are there
like mentors or or
teachers whatever the case preparing for
baptism do you go through any kind of
courses what i'm saying is do they help
young people through this are you kind
of just thrown in the deep end so
because i was a child when it happened
she my mother was the one going through
the the the training and the rituals and
all this other stuff and because we were
her children she was doing these things
for us so we had to i think we had to
like eat in certain way and then we take
these special baths you know every day
i think it was like for seven days and
and then we would go to this house and
she would you know we would be put in
his room while she was sacrificing
chickens
and casting spells and is that even
legal
no
that's why it's secret i mean well i
mean
it is legal in the united states when
you're eating your your kentucky fried
chicken right right yeah technically it
is
when you're talking about some of these
rituals
i don't know if maybe this will help
somebody to catch on if somebody else
maybe somebody's like curious do i know
anybody that practices this since
they're not real open about it
i know a guy personally
and i don't want to say too much but he
knows somebody very close to him uh
who is involved in this and she for like
an entire year
had to wear nothing but pure white yeah
she had it was literally this is how
deceptive satan is
it's being born again yes you're she had
to live as an infant for an entire year
wearing nothing but white i guess eating
like baby food and stuff and being fed i
don't know if it's baby food but she was
being fed by her spouse wow and things
like that wow have you ever heard of
that um i haven't heard of that
specifically well the white yes okay yes
because we had to wear
we had to wear some white clothes
um i mean
for like a certain amount of time but
yeah
yeah for a certain amount of time i
think it was seven days so like probably
before your baptism you're aware
yes interesting yeah okay so how long
did these dreams last how long was this
figure this man standing by your bedside
oh man
the dreams lasted well after i became a
christian
and here's why
well
backtrack
years of of
hurt and pain you know when you when you
welcome the devil into your life bad
things are going to happen i was
molested as a child by multiple people
you know
i was
going through a lot of hardships in
school
even though it was a christian school it
was catholic school um you know being
picked on and bullied and all that other
stuff and then you know being rejected
in so many ways on so many levels by so
many people that are supposed to care
for you and love you and all the other
stuff it sends you down this like
lifestyle spiraling
and i remember committing my life to to
to
not being a good person anymore
i remember saying
that i am not going to be
a good person and i kept saying it over
and over again over and over again
once i did that my life changed for the
worse
um went into drugs went into alcoholism
got into a lot of trouble got involved a
lot of people who were involved in
serious gangs dated you know
gang members and
you know drugs almost got arrested a few
times and you know just crazy life that
happened and then um in order to protect
myself i went to the only thing that i
knew
an interesting question that comes to
mind as i think about that is the way
you're describing your interaction with
what you knew yeah
and you go to that for protection
i look back on everything and say
what were you really getting
that's a really good question no the the
payoff doesn't seem like it's there
you're talking about all these
struggles but then you keep going back
to something that's demanding of you
yeah and not giving you anything yep and
that's what changed my life that makes
you say
why go back yeah right
yeah it doesn't it doesn't make sense
from an intellectual standpoint that you
would go back yeah
so
i'm curious why i go back you know i i
get it familiarity you know it's like
it's what you know yeah but it's like
for your mom and it makes me wonder
about your grandma like what was the
payoff
well the thing is is that when you're in
it
you just you believe because it's it's
it's within yourself it's within your
own power and so if you're not
dedicating your life enough to it then
you're not experiencing the full power
of it
so that's why you have to so then you
have to question yourself as are you
really giving yourself fully to it and
then that's when i made a decision to
give myself fully to it which is very
works based
it is it is it's all it's all really
back on you yes you're the one that has
to perform all these things and then
constantly questioning whether
everything you're doing is good enough
yes and i can see in that kind of a
system
the abuse of power because the more you
give the more that's going to be
demanded of you yep
that's how the devil works right i mean
you need to do all this stuff so you
want power
you need to do drugs sacrifice killing
this and it's just your life going down
down
so there's two parts to unpacking this
question because you have the pact and
then you have can it be broken so
looking at the pact
do you think
making a pact with the devil is like a
one-time thing like an initiation or is
it little pieces added up for a
lifestyle that is symbolic of a pact
maybe it's both i think it's a
combination i think it's definitely a
combination but once you initiate it
it's almost like this feeling like um
you can't get out of it
once you initiate it you start it and
then you got to keep the ball rolling
yeah and you will not experience its
effects unless you keep the ball rolling
yeah so there's there's a heavy
commitment to it which is it brings up
another interesting thought in my mind
is that you know
the devil has this
mentality that
i'm not going to let you go
but god doesn't do that
god says
it's painful to me
but i will let you go
because it's your choice so true it is
very true
when did it when did you really start
feeling the effects like wow this is too
much and what did you do about it
the effects well
once i started going into it and started
you know going into the spells started
doing um
the various things that i needed to do
did card reading you know went to
various santeras went to this there's a
place that you go to actually to get all
of these things and to meet asantera
and it is it's called botanica
botanica is they have all the statues
they have all the candles they have all
this you know and um
you know the spells the oils the
whatever it is that you need to cast a
spell
and i remember
going in over there and i i started to
do things and i started to experience
um the power
i started to experience
things that would happen it would always
come in a dream but the more i
experience these these things happening
on my behalf
i started to experience more tragedies
in my life and more torment in my life
that would lead me to go chasing it even
deeper
so botanica is like a store it's a store
it sounds like uh botanical like yes
which
just kind of is a weird thought because
a lot of times when the israelites
apostasize it was like in a grove
bohemian grove and things like that not
saying there's a connection there i'm
just saying it's because i'm pretty sure
there is kind of but there's a store you
physically go to yeah i mean is this
like just anybody can walk in or you
gotta have to know where it is you know
give the secret password or whatever you
know it's behind this locked door
no anybody can i mean yeah that there's
a huge sign that says botanica
you walk in like the store but this is
probably like anybody can buy whatever
but then there's probably like a secret
room there is a secret room yeah okay
yes there is a secret room and you have
to ask and
you know of course
you know you pay a lot of money to go
ahead and go into that secret room and
to do whatever it is that they you're
asking them to do
but i do remember
everything just kind of like
was at its peak you know i had
turmoil on all sides of the spectrum
like things were just happening like
and i couldn't you can't even explain it
with a thing after another after another
after another after another and so um
i've had i had people who were
actually out to harm me
for various reasons and
so i went to a botanica because i
need to figure out what to do
i need to figure out what to do and i
remember
i would have i would have these
nightmares of
tarantulas crawling up me
spiders
rats snakes um
somebody's killing me um i was always
fighting in my dream so much so so
strongly that i would like get up and
like i'd be swinging
um
screaming
um were you the only one experiencing
this yes yes none of your siblings your
mom wasn't they didn't really uh embrace
it as much as i did okay yeah my
siblings didn't embrace as much as i did
even though they did experience a lot of
issues because of it you know because it
was in the family
they weren't well aware with it i mean i
would have visions and dreams of things
happening that it would happen like i
had a dream that my brother was going to
have an accident he was going to have a
bloody face and then a few days later it
happened um you know
um
i would i would be talking in different
languages and other things would be
talking to me i would i would meet with
like a native american you know
saint or god whatever it is and he'd be
talking to me in his language and i'd be
responding to him um um did you
understand what was being said
very clearly very very clearly it's the
demonic tongues and stuff yeah and they
were giving me instructions on what to
do and how to do it um
could have probably felt really
isolating since
no one in your family could really
relate to that
huh
i'm just sitting there going here they
are giving you instructions telling you
what to do but i still go back to this
other thought like you're having these
problems but they're not helping you
want you to figure out what to do yeah
yeah yeah
wow and there's actually a story in the
bible that actually brought that to
light that's exactly what
drove it home for me to like question
and say what what is this
um
for how long you had you were practicing
all this stuff
five years seven years one of you
decided like you know what it's gonna go
very
deep um
i think i started when i was like 15 or
15 or 16.
until
until about
yeah until about 20. and that's when i
was introduced to my first bible and but
backtracking
um
you said that you were experiencing this
dream as well into becoming a christian
well when did christianity even enter
within that world of centuria yeah so i
i hit a peak i felt like my life was at
danger
i didn't know exactly what i was going
to do i thought i was going to die satan
had told me that i actually had a
conversation with the devil wow um um
and he told me was this in a dream it
was in a dream it was in a dream i it
was during the afternoon i was taking a
nap i could never sleep at night time so
i always slept during the day because at
night time the the torment was so strong
that i just i just i was too scared so i
i literally was forced into insomnia
wow
and so one afternoon i had a dream with
him and um that somebody had given me my
first bible
and
he
he was he was a very attractive
man
he had a very handsome face
uh an amazing voice like his voice was
so like drawing that it was very it was
very appealing because it's satan it was
satan
and so i was uh in a dark area
and he was talking to me and he asked me
to do something for him
and um
i had a really big attitude
and my attitude was i'm not gonna do
anything unless you tell me what it is
and so he
um asked me to do something for him he
said will you do this for me commit to
it and i said tell me what it is and
i'll tell you if i can do it.
he says no i want you to do it or
you know
and i'll tell you what it is i said
i said tell me what you want me to do
and i will tell you if i can do it
and he said um
you're gonna do it
he said no you're gonna do it i want you
to do this and i said no
and as i was trying to leave this
the presence of this person he became
very aggressive
he became very
strong and unpleasant and um
he started to threaten me
and in that moment
when i was i said you know i'm done i
don't want to i don't want to have any
i'm not doing it no the answer is no let
me go
i couldn't wake up
now in i was in my room taking a nap i
had my phone with me my cousin was
outside the door um of my bedroom the
door ended up being locked
and the phone would not ring no matter
how many times she called and he held me
down i couldn't breathe he was holding
me down and he was telling me you're
going to do this you're going to do this
if you don't do this this is going to
happen and he showed me a picture a
family portrait of my of of you know my
family and um
in that picture all their faces became
very distorted
and demonic looking
and
i knew what that was and then as my
cousin was outside she said she called
in the name of jesus and then it broke
it broke i woke up and
um
and so that was my experience little did
i know that he kept he really stayed
true to what he said
because then i became a christian i had
my first bible i started to search but
there was like the struggle there was
definitely a struggle there was torment
i would be on the highway driving and he
would give me a vision and i'd come out
of my car and he would show me that he
was going to make me drive off a cliff
wow and every every day i would drive to
work i would hate driving over a bridge
because i thought he was going to do it
and he did try once
one time i was driving on the highway
this car just came and swooped over and
nobody saw the car i saw it
i saw the car and it sent me spinning in
the highway in a five-lane highway
and thankfully by god's grace i ended up
in the emergency lane and i mean there
was heavy traffic not not a scratch
not a scratch and everybody just kept
going nobody stopped or anything one
woman stopped but i mean like the car
that did this to you just kept going
nobody saw the car wow the one woman who
stopped she was like i don't know what
happened that was crazy you know she
hugged me and i remember just crying and
then that what brought me to the
botanica
i brought i came to the botanical and i
said i need protection
um but you're christian you were
introduced to christianity i still had
this bible i couldn't read it i remember
trying to read it and i couldn't
understand it it was like it was like a
foreign language to me so i had it so
there was a desire for it but it wasn't
something that i understood i could
relate to i could understand i couldn't
connect with it um even though i wanted
to so bad so i go to this botanica and
as i was at the botanical
i'm waiting
and this
now i live in
in a city where it's like very very very
multicultural i mean you have every just
about every country represented there
and a botanical is usually like hispanic
people well this white woman comes out
and she was very nice
very nice short hair
and she said how could i help you and i
said well i would like your strongest
mode of protection
and i'd wholeheartedly believe that she
was a guardian angel
she said
the strongest thing you have is your
faith
just like that just like that
and i just looked at everything i
remember looking at the display the
glass display looking at her looking at
all the statues behind her
i said okay and i walked out
wow but i knew right then and there the
holy spirit said it's god
it's god
and so that kind of sent me into
chasing christianity and then that's
when the torment started to come
really strong
strong upon me yeah if she worked there
surely she would have a product for you
exactly this is what you need yeah she
would have given me something and she
would have probably told me to cast some
spells and took me to the back and
it's like god's speaking through her i
wonder if she even knew what she was
saying i'm not even sure open-ended
right which allowed space to be like oh
maybe maybe it's this book that i
haven't read yet yeah no none of that
none of that wow so in the case of can
this pact be broken how did it work how
did it break
well it didn't break um immediately so i
came into the church i was baptized and
i you know i love the lord and i was in
church the christian church and i was ex
you know just doing things i was on fire
for god i was you know i love ministry i
love youth ministry i love going out and
preaching i love door knocking i love
praying with people random people i love
talking to anybody you could talk to me
i could the teacher my teacher used to
say that i could sit next to a pumpkin
and i would talk to him
so i had no fear as far as like going
out and evangelizing none at all
but i still had this problem i still had
these nightmares i still had this
torment
what were some of the steps from that
lady saying it's your faith and you had
a bible from there to where you're
talking about you're an on-fire
christian i mean
did your cousin you said your cousin
knocked on the door
and said the name of jesus is
she kind of helping you no she didn't
she didn't help um it was um
other people actually strangers you just
started running into christians
everywhere like yeah yeah guys god is
great yeah i've seen that happen many
times yeah and and incidentally like and
you know they weren't
you know of the faith that i went i went
to various churches and and every time i
went to different churches i would i
would pick up on on a lot of the things
that were like
reminded me of the satanic things that
didn't sit well with me so i would go to
that church i'm like nope don't like
that go to that church no i didn't like
that no i didn't like that one and then
i found one wow
of scary it is very very scary
it wasn't until i i
i literally thought
that the devil
would never let go of his grip of me
i never thought because of the torment
because of the dreams the nightmares and
things like that i never thought he
would and so i forever believed even
though i was baptized and a christian
and active in the church
that i was gonna forever and he was
gonna take me out one day did it ever
occur to you
did it ever click
with what your cousin did
cousin called in the name of jesus
you're still having these dreams and
visions and problems yeah to do the same
yeah for yourself did you ever call on
the name of jesus during those times and
notice anything get better or did it
just never
come to mind it never occurred to me
until one day i there was a youth
evangelism
uh series at the church that i was at
and as i was there
they were talking about the power of god
now when you experience the devil and
his power
you know he has power
you know
but when you experience god and you
experience his power and you come to a
realization that he has more power
that
was a turning point for me
amen
that was when i started to call in the
name of jesus
in my nightmares and my dreams
that was when i
told satan you have no power over me
none whatsoever god is stronger do you
think that maybe that thought was
influenced by
your education as a young person
in catholic school like you mentioned
earlier they didn't talk about jesus
much so
for you you know if all these things are
being elevated and they're not talking
about
that then maybe it just never clicked
that yeah jesus has power yeah well
because there's an an element that uh
in in the church and not to
i'm not bashing the catholic church at
all this is just my personal experience
and i know that there are many people
who've experienced it including my
family i've talked to my siblings since
then the lord is working with my family
and um and and it's very similar to that
but there's a strong
emphasis that if you are experiencing
turmoil if you're experiencing issues
it's because you're being punished
and so if you're being punished you're
kind of being thrown off to the devil
at his
whatever things you deserve it
you deserve what you're getting because
you know you did something so similar to
judaism you know
if somebody's born blind or paralyzed
well it's a judgment from god i mean
you're obviously doing something wrong
in your family yes
yes interesting and there's definitely a
belief even if you're not doing anything
wrong
there's also a belief that you are
reincarnated and whoever somebody didn't
back in your life before
you're paying for that in santeria
yeah
so not in catholicism
yes in santoria okay yeah
yeah but that's not biblical teaching so
but you're you're experiencing these
issues these troubles while being a
christian yeah so
how did you reconcile that why did you
keep going back to christianity despite
having these issues did that
mess with your faith at all like where
where are you god like i'm having all
these issues i've given my heart to you
why am i still experiencing this yeah it
did it did uh
i still looked at god as a tyrant god
the father as a tyrant
but i looked at jesus as somebody who
could relate to me
and i always kind of separated the two
and you can't
you know you can't separate them
you know jesus is an is he
is an expression of his father and in
all his ways and all his doings
if you've seen him you've seen the
father exactly exactly
and what helped me to reconcile these
this thought into my mind was uh in
first kings chapter 18 when a lie elijah
and going back to what you're saying
keith
that
there's this
okay
i've been doing this for so long
it's not working
why is it not working and then he was
able to show me through through the
through that passage
that is because they're not god
you know and then i recognize oh
that's why it never worked oh and then i
was
it it it really deepened my
understanding
of the power of god
now experiencing god's love
was something that i had to go on
another journey yeah
so explain the pact being broken
the freedom that that brought
oh my goodness
to be able to sleep at night
i
i remember how
happy i was
when i woke up the next morning and i
realized that i slept a full night
i i don't even know how long i slept i
probably slept a long time
and i i just couldn't like the woman at
the well when when you know it was just
like look you know i'm sleeping guys
everyone's like okay yeah great
um
that experience of freedom and to know
that god
does care
on a deep level that i'm not just some
tiny little speck that is just
insignificant and just thrown and he's
not just some arbitrary god who's just
looking to just punish him and and do
that he he wants to help he wants to set
free he wants us to be and experience
this perfect peace this perfect joy this
perfect love and once i got that
i mean there was no stopping me but how
how how did he do it how did he allow
you to experience that piece you're
having these dreams and you're having
these interactions with the devil
how did god step in
well when i started to call in the name
of jesus in in the midst of my dreams
and the dream would stop
okay you know the the dream would stop
and then i would be able to go back to
sleep if i had a nightmare and i woke up
and i would force myself to wake up it
would always pick up where i left off or
start all over again
but it was those times when i started to
implement yes god you are the power you
know jesus you know you can you know
stop this right now
and then
that's when it i i practiced it and i
started to live it
so there is power in the name of jesus
oh there is
there is
do you still get those dreams from time
to time now
um
he doesn't attack the same way that he
used to he definitely attacks in in
other ways
the only other times that i've i've
experienced those nightmares when i've
been in the presence or with people who
are having that
in their lives and i've learned since
then
that i needed to
pray and and and call on the name of
jesus beforehand
you know knowing and then that i'm
protected
for me there was a kind of a different
story i was
messing around with the occult ouija
boards and things like that and i think
god had a protection on me to keep me
from seeing too much power in it because
i was searching and if i would have seen
a lot of power in that i would have went
right for it yeah but it seemed like
somebody would be playing ouija board
and work and i'd get on there and it
wouldn't
and
then at some point a chain of events
brought me to
the bible in christianity i accepted
christ but i was not living it at all i
mean i was
if you ask me if i'm a christian yeah i
believe in all this
but i was living just like the world
i mean every aspect of my life even
daily smoking weed and drinking beer and
doing rap shows and all this
and i never experienced spiritual
warfare never experienced
those dreams and things like that yeah
it was after i committed fully to god
that i started having those so new
year's 2013 i really surrendered
everything everything to god and that
was the first time in my life that i
would
wake up terrified to open my eyes
because i know there's like a demonic
presence right in front of me and i
would pray spiritual warfare the moment
i said the name of jesus instant peace
and that's where satan was like
he was angry and so he's trying to
attack me thinking does he know how to
combat me does he know spiritual warfare
and so i i can remember like three
distinct times that that really happened
and i would pray spiritual warfare and
then there was times that
it would happen to my daughter or
something like that like there was like
two different times that something
happened like that to my daughter yeah
so i felt like
and i tell people when you really commit
like when they're talking to me about
you know how do you get free from
addictions and these things
i tell them i say satan when you're when
you're one foot in the world one foot in
the church satan leaves you alone
because he knows if he starts tormenting
you you're going to run to god it's
going to push you closer to god because
you're scared
so satan doesn't really mess with you
you're
you're already in his camp you're
lukewarm yeah
but when you fully surrender to him it
makes him angry and he starts attacking
yes and we have to know how
to tap into the power like you're saying
yeah yeah i'm reminded of the the the
story in the bible where
the demoniac started to come towards
jesus
and you know the the disciples you know
hightailed it out but then he just put
his hand out and you can't go any
further
so when we tap into god that way when we
recognize and acknowledge that he has
that power to say you can't come any
further that's when you're able to
that's when you're able to practice it
and then you're experiencing it
and and that you know of course satan
has to come in a different angle right
yeah because you could you might have
all the belief but when you get attacked
you don't
you're not familiar with what to do yeah
he's hoping he can catch you in that
spot and sometimes he might even not
attack you you personally um you know
directly he's he may start actually
going to the people around you yeah oh
yeah
and that's exactly what happened to me
that's a good point because coming out
of that lifestyle it's not just a change
in mindset when you become a christian
it's a change in lifestyle it's a change
in community so what happened to your
previous community your family well he
he kept his promise
with that picture
and my family they
hated me and they didn't know why they
you know
i just
you know they had their their reasons
and they were very cheap reasons
um
but i it went i went five years after i
became a christian i went five years
without talking to them wow
five years they didn't want to talk to
me no matter how many times i reached
out
no matter how many times but
um by god's grace i have a very blessed
relationship with them
the lord has
brought reconciliation he's brought
peace he's brought yes and he's restored
them all unto me
and even though my relationship with
them is different and
um
they're still you know
i love them and and they love me and now
our relationship
it is really funny because
they kind of look to me as the person
who understands god and is connected
with god and knows god and whereas
before they were really just that's
usually how it works and not to diminish
the pain that comes with that kind of
separation but i can see why it's
necessary it was definitely necessary
urge and make sure your connection with
christ is solid without having a bunch
of opinions around you exactly yeah
exactly but praise the lord that there's
some reconciliation yes
i heard a quote that always stuck with
me and said i i prayed for god to remove
my enemies and i started losing friends
yeah because you're in family
and i think that they
didn't hate you they hated christ in you
jesus said they will hate you for my
name say his character's sake and he
says that they're really persecuting him
and he talks about how
darkness hates the light yes they're
like like when you flip the light on
like cockroaches they run yes
and that's that's what it is you were
glowing you had something you had christ
in you and i stopped drinking i stopped
doing drugs i stopped partying i stopped
doing and you would think that i started
going to school and you know these are
great right it's like why are you mad at
me it's a conviction to them you're
living something that's convicting them
about what they're doing yes yeah and i
like just the hope that comes with your
future and how you can influence
influence other people in your family
because it's like what satan thought
that he had a foothold on he's losing
power every single day and i can only
have every single day yeah every single
moment okay he probably like he probably
hates your family right now more than
they probably hate him oh he hates me
he hates me let me tell you something
i'm gonna be a part of the hundred and
forty four thousand i'm cleaning it
let's do it okay so he's going to hate
me
there's a text in um
roman 6 that i think goes well with this
episode
says what then shall we send because we
are not under the law but under grace
certainly not
do you not know that to whom you present
yourselves slaves to obey
you are that one slaves when you obey
whether of sin leading to death or of
obedience leading to righteousness
the old testament uses some interesting
language
and particularly jeremiah where
it says
that the israelites served other
gods and they would burn incense to them
and things like that
and
oftentimes
the the people and surrounding nations
would think those other gods were these
idols of wood and stone and
metals or whatever
and they weren't really those they were
demonic forces that were behind
all of those yeah it says but thank but
god be thanked that though you were
slaves of sin yet you obeyed from the
heart that form of doctrine to which you
were delivered and having been set free
from sin you became slaves of
righteousness which is a
a foreign concept to us these days we
don't we don't like the idea of being
under anybody's control or being a slave
right but that's the way that that paul
describes it he says i speak in human
terms because of the weakness of your
flesh for just as you presented your
members as slaves of uncleanness and of
lawlessness leading to more lawlessness
so now present your members as slaves of
righteousness
for holiness
amen for when you were slaves of sin you
were free in regard to righteousness
in one sense
everybody's a slave
right
but one form of slavery will keep you in
slavery yeah the other form of slavery
will set you free
that's right
yeah
yeah i have um
i just want to know
have you ever shared this story with
someone and they didn't believe you or
they made you feel like your story was
less than because i know often some
people who haven't experienced the
spiritual forces of this world they can
easily say oh i mean maybe you're just
hallucinating so have you ever
experienced that never to my face
i think that's a beautiful about
testimonies you know i mean i cannot
deny what you went through
i mean that's what you what you went
through and what the lord protect you
bless you deliver you
and all this craziness of the enemy's
power yeah and then thank you for
sharing you know
your testimony and i was awesome i don't
know if somebody else can't
someone who might be in the position you
were in wrestling
century or maybe they do have that bible
sitting on their shelf and they don't
even know like how to even approach it
yeah you have anything to say to them
that's a good question
there's power in the blood of jesus
and if you cannot pick up that bible and
understand what it says
you could still call in the name of
jesus and it still has that same power
i definitely
have
sympathy and pity
for people who are
living their life day by day without
jesus
you know it's easy to go ahead and point
the finger and say oh this person is
doing this and doing that and you know
they're playing that music and listening
to that and watching this and watching
that
but it's like no
what are you looking for really
that's true what are you looking for
because we're all looking for something
right we're all looking for
that that sense of purpose that sense of
belonging that sense that love
that loved love has always been my
driving force i've always desired that
love and i know so many people are going
through and so
i have this
thing where
i feel like i want to save the world
you know i know that i can't do it
personally
but through jesus christ
now again i'm gonna say it again i'm
gonna be a part of the hundred forty
four thousand mark my words is on tv
um
through his power we'll be able to save
as many people as possible
so i've dedicated my life to doing that
is there anything in media and culture
today that you encounter that
gives you that kind of gut check
reaction where you're like oh that
reminds me of
my past
yeah
there's so much
i mean it's almost as if
it's almost as if where can you go
where can you go now to to not see or
have or
sense the influence of
satan's
[Music]
power or
hold stronghold on people or things or
situations and there's influence right
that's true like i don't even have a
cable tv or anything but i'm pumping gas
and there's
the addams family you know blasting in
your face and it's like dude i can't
even or go to the grocery store and that
song comes on or whatever i mean and
here we are in october now in this
halloween stuff and there are people
already practicing already excited about
halloween in august and i'm just
and that's something that's so
interesting to me because i used to
watch horror movies a lot oh yeah me too
and i always wondered why whenever like
whenever there's a spirit coming towards
them or harming them they always like
it's usually the catholic religion that
they like they call the priest to come
and do these things splash water have
the rosary and it never works
i used to think they are mocking jesus
right now but it's like i don't know it
just seems like is there something false
about the like jesus like jesus power
would not do that like it would be able
to cast these demons out but they stay
and they end up overwhelming the priest
or the priest runs away you know right
so right i just always wondered i i was
i'm delivered from that i no longer
watch scary movies but they used to be
something in these films they're
actually saying the name of jesus no no
they don't they just have like the
rosaries and they're just splashing over
the holy water and you see like the
steam coming up but it's always
associated with the catholic church yeah
the flip side of that if ever
any
christian religion works it is
catholicism
like if if you're gonna get married it's
always in a catholic church if you're
gonna exercise the demon or whatever
it's always because like in the movie
exorcist that
she did freak out when he was
so they make the catholic church look
powerful and i think there's an agenda
behind that yeah totally that goes to
what tammy was saying in her upbringing
experiences with the catholic church in
school
jesus name wasn't even mentioned right
so
i guess keeping the the truth hidden
right in that sense in that aspect right
like the powers in the holy water the
powers and the symbol of this cross
right now
right
so i believe that satan is very very
heavily
influencing the young people through
disney and through a lot of those
not just disney cartoons and
that's crazy you know last year i mean
uh mikey and i we did this this
presentation you know
modern witchcraft and how disney was
just
friendly like so loaded
black magic you know with the k right
and this
movie is like like 9 10 11 12 years old
kids practicing that kind of stuff yes
and to me it's like you know you were
living it practicing
go through it and deliver it yeah when
you see those kind of movies just for a
young child i mean can you imagine i was
there evil
satanism indoctrination and just because
they have a
beautiful name the company and glitter
it's just for a little kid you know it's
just wonder i mean what do you think i
mean that's so
evil i think that that parents should be
very very careful and and aware that
satan
like i said in in my dream with the
devil he was handsome and he did
sound you know very appealing and he
will package everything nicely
and and give it to you and
you're eating something rotten
you're eating something rotten wow it's
almost always the same pattern though
at first it looks really nice yes
and then when the refusal comes
then he starts comes off yeah
right there's no more mr nice guy after
that that's right and it's force i'm
gonna make you yes
and he inflects that personality on
jesus so it's like i've grown up
thinking jesus is what appears to be
satan's personality you know
and it's just man
he's such a meanie yeah
so how you share the gospel because you
were saying like you you you
you so excited about sharing the gospel
you have a book about your story a
website
i mean it has to be shared right i mean
what do you do are you part of some
ministry i'm not i'm just a a one-woman
show yeah
i just do what i do
i'm a midwife i'm a volunteer
firefighter i'm a mentor for a teen mom
group
i
get involved in everything that i can
possibly get into i'm a life coach as
well so i i i mentor a lot of young
people
a lot of teens how would people get in
touch with you on that stuff
um well mainly the probably the life
coach i would think the life coaching uh
they could
probably contact me by email okay we'll
put that right here it's amazing what
christ in your heart and a good night's
sleep will allow you to do
girl let me tell you
after this i'm gonna go on vacation i'm
gonna have a lot of sleep all right so
yeah thank you so much tammy for being
on the show thank you guys for having me
what an amazing testimonial
and um so
if you make a pact with the devil can it
be broken absolutely
and it's through the power of jesus
christ
and for anyone watching who may have
resonated with tammy's story who can
identify with the things that she's
going through please keep that in your
heart that yes through the power of
jesus in his name alone you can be set
free and there are so many resources out
there we are here to support you we are
here to help you even if it's just for
you to give us a call you can find our
number on our website little
lightstudios.tv
to give us a call for us to pray with
you for us to
find out where you are maybe help you
connect with the church um there's power
in the name of jesus and there is no one
too far gone there is no pact that is
too great where god can't reach in there
and save
thank you so much for watching led live
we will see you next week have a blessed
day bye-bye
[Music]
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the duelist who they say can speak
with the spirits the sins will destroy
the commandments forever a suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern from
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
visit our brothers at school for
prophets dot tv and watch from babylon
to america which has over 5 million
views on youtube alone and follow it up
with america 2 babylon check the
description below for links to this and
more
[Music]
you